en este vídeo lo que quiero ver es si
tomar la transpuesta de una matriz
afecta en algo al determinante así que
vamos a empezar con el caso más sencillo
que es el caso de las matrices de 2 x 2
supongan sé que tengo una matriz de 2 x
2 que qué forma tiene que tener pues
tiene que ser ave
y voy a tomar su determinante recuerden
que cuando no pongo paréntesis cuadrados
rodeando la matriz si no pongo estas
líneas significa determinante entonces
quién es el determinante una matriz de 2
por 2 pues ustedes ya lo saben es por de
a por de menos de porce perfecto ahora
qué pasa si trans pongo esta matriz que
obtendría tengo que intercambiar
renglones por columnas entonces esta
matriz se convierte en hace de t
y quién es el determinante pues de nuevo
es por de menos b por se noten que lo
único que pasó al transponer fue que se
intercambiaron b y c pero como si van a
multiplicar no pasó absolutamente nada
así que el caso de matrices de 2 x 2 si
ya es de 2 x 2
entonces
su determinante el determinante de a es
igual al determinante de a transpuesta
muy bien ahora para ver qué se vale para
todos los enteros para matrices de n por
n lo voy a hacer por inducción inducción
inducción matemática y cómo funciona la
inducción pues lo primero que tengo que
hacer es suponer
supongo
supongo que funciona
para toda matriz ve de nm
de este simbolito significa para toda
matriz bdn por n el determinante de b
determinante de b es igual al
determinante de b transpuesta
y dado eso dado eso
quiero usar otro color
dado esto de aquí
voy a probar
y suponiendo esto pruebo que entonces se
vale
se vale para
matrices
y matrices de
n 1
por n 1
y si este es el caso si esto es cierto
si se vale para matrices de n por n
entonces se vale para matrices de n más
uno por n 1
entonces ya acabé porque como se vale
para matrices de 2 x 2
entonces se vale para matrices de 3 por
3 pero como se vale para matrices de 3
por 3 se vale para matrices de 4x4 y así
sucesivamente así que habría probado que
en efecto esto es válido para matrices
de de n por n con n mayor o igual a 2 el
caso de n igual a 1 es completamente
trivial y se los dejo ejercicio
bien pues de que me pongo una matriz a
siempre usaba para matrices de n 1
n 1
y simplemente porque es más simple voy a
llamar a este número de aquí a n 1 lo
voy a llamar m 12m y esto va a ser m ok
entonces quién es mi matriz a como se ve
pues vamos a ver
la matriz y se va a ver algo así va a
ser a 11 a 12 a 13
hasta
hasta a 1 m recuerden que ms n 1
segundo renglón sería a 21 a 22 a 23
hasta a 12 m
tercer renglón a 3 1 a 3 2
a 33 hasta hasta a 3 m y así podría
continuar no lo voy a hacer pero podrían
seguir hasta llegar hasta a m1 m2
a m3
y seguirse hasta a m m así que esta es
mi matriz a donde claro esta columna
sigue
esto sigue y esto sigue y aquí también
hay cosas de enmedio bien entonces ya
que tengo a quién está transpuesta tiene
es mi matriz ha transpuesto de nuevo va
a ser de n 1 por n
o dicho de otro modo de m por m y quien
es pues es el resultado de intercambiar
columnas y renglones así que voy a
agarrar este primer renglón y lo voy a
escribir como una columna va a ser a 11
a 12 a 13
hasta
a 1 m
bien ahora mi segundo renglón es este de
aquí lo escribo como mi segunda columna
a-21 a-22 y a-23 hasta
a 12 m
bien tercer renglón se convierte en la
tercera columna a 3 1 a 3 2
a 33
y a 3 m sé que no sólo escribir tantas
entradas en las matrices pero en este
caso creo que será útil ok entonces
continúa para acá y terminaría en a m 1
a m2
a m3
y finalmente
a m m
y aquí con todo lo que esté en medio muy
bien esa es mi transpuesta ahora bien
necesito comparar el determinante de
esta matriz con el determinante de esta
otra matriz muy bien quién es el
determinante de la matriz a esto eso
sabe muy bien que por ejemplo no podría
desarrollar a partir del primer renglón
y usar la llamada fórmula de la plástico
regla de la plaza y ella me diría que él
determine determinante idea es a 1-1
por el determinante de la matriz que
obtengo de eliminar el primer renglón y
la primera columna que voy a llamar a 11
así que a 11 es esta sub matriz de aquí
es esta su matriz de aquí esto es
a 11 luego menos a 12 por el
determinante de la matriz que obtengo al
eliminar el primer renglón y la segunda
columna así que esa la voy a llamar a 12
ya ves a esta anotación antes y así
continúa sumando continúa sumando hasta
que llegó a el término que corresponde a
1 m pero lleva signo menos 1 a la m1
esto quiere decir más menos más menos
más menos hasta que llegó aquí y será
menos 17 spar y 17 es impar
y acá sería a 1 m por el determinante de
la sub matriz a 1 m que sería el
resultado de eliminar primer renglón y
primera columna me quedaría ahora con
todo lo que está por acá
ahora bien quién es el determinante de a
transpuesta quién es el determinante de
a transpuesta pues nosotros sabemos que
en vez de irnos por el primer renglón
también nos podríamos ir por la primera
columna
así que vamos a desarrollar el
determinante pero mediante la primera
columna así que de nuevo tendría a 11
por el determinante por el determinante
de la matriz las matriz que obtengo de
quitar este renglón y esta columna
así que si quito eso lo que me queda es
esto de aquí
pero tienes esto de aquí pues se
observan estoy aquí es a 22 a 23 hasta a
12 m nada más que ahora está en una
columna en vez de en un renglón luego a
32 que está aquí a 33 hasta 13 m que de
nuevo antes en un renglón y ahora está
en una columna así que en realidad es el
determinante de a 1-1 transpuesta
- ahora quien a 12
a 12 por el determinante de quien ahora
lo que voy a hacer es quitar a
voy a tratar de usar este color voy a
quitar a este renglón
esta columna y entonces lo que me queda
sería la matriz que tiene a esto
y que tiene a esto tienen que pegar las
dos mitades de la matriz
y ahora bien quién es eso pues es lo
mismo a ver si aquí tachó este y tachó
este entonces me quedo con esto
y me quedo con esto de acá
y fíjense de nuevo la primera columna de
esta matriz sería a 21 a 23 hasta a 12 m
que es el primer renglón de esta matriz
el segundo renglón perdón la segunda
columna de esta matriz sería el segundo
renglón de esta matriz así que en
realidad esto es
1 2 transpuesta transpuesta y así voy a
continuar voy a continuar hasta que
llegué aquí a la entrada aún no m
qué va a llevar signo -1 a la 1pm oa la
m1 y va a ser a 1 m por el determinante
de la sub matriz híjole esto ya se hizo
un revoltijo de lo peor por la sub
matriz que contiene a todas las entradas
menos las que están en la primera
columna y en el último renglón así que
sería esta de acá pero quién es eso pues
es la atrás pues está de la matriz que
contiene a todas las entradas menos en
esta matriz las que están en el primer
renglón o en la última columna así que
esto aquí va a ser
a 1 m transpuesta
y perdonen un poco el relajo que se armó
aquí pero creo que entienden la idea el
punto es que la sub matriz de la que
tengo que tomar el determinante siempre
va a ser la transporta de la sub matriz
de la entrada correspondiente en mi
matriz original pues muy bien porque
recuerden que estamos haciendo una
inducción así que tenía la suposición de
que se valía para matrices de n por n
estas dos matrices de aquí está y ésta
estas dos son matrices de n 1 por n 1
pero estás está
y estas son matrices de n por n
ésta y ésta al igual que estas dos son
de n por m esta i
y así en todos los casos así que mi
hipótesis inductiva la hipótesis
inductiva me decía que el determinante
debe donde verá cualquier matriz de n
por ende era igual al determinante de la
trans puesta
entonces simplemente puedo cambiar todas
las respuestas aquí por la matriz sin
transponer es decir esto es lo mismo que
el determinante de 11 menos 12 por el
determinante de a 12 y así
así hasta llegar a menos 1 a la m 1 x 1
m por el determinante de a 1 m muy bien
pero entonces esta fórmula la que está
aquí abajo en morado coincide con la
fórmula que está aquí en amarillo para
el determinante de a así que
efectivamente lo que he probado es el
caso de n 1
por m + 1 es decir provee que el
determinante de a
es igual a el determinante de a
transpuesta sí
se vale sí es cierto
sí es cierto para matrices
para matrices
de m por m pero entonces ya acabé porque
ya lo había probado acá arriba lo provee
para matrices de 2 por 2 y entonces esto
lo que me dices ah ok ya lo probaste
para matrices de 2 x 2
entonces se vale para matrices de dos
más uno por dos más uno sea matrices de
tres por tres y si se vale para las de
tres personas se vale para las de cuatro
por cuatro y así sucesivamente así que
en efecto acabamos de probar esto por
inducción para matrices de n por n para
cualquier n mayor igual a 2 en resumen
si aplicas la transpuesta el
determinante no cambia